Yeah. I think that. The community certainly didn't seem a as any sort of guru or.
As any sort of highly qualified or addict. Counselor. People didn't come to me for counseling and i didn't treat me in.
In public theater's as if i had anything particular to offer. The various debates because of.
I was working in lease more as a psychiatrist and i was therefore very much a part of the dominant paradigm. So i was.
That part of me that aspect to me being a psychiatrist i. I think i just rejected. That.
Fortunately i had an alter ego i was amused.
And i think an awful lot of people really to rely to me as a talented musician i was only working part time
and so i was i will do a lot of music and. Teach at the local community school and do all of those sorts of things.
My identity as a psychiatrist wasn't important. Except as i said with the policeman to some extent.
And my be with the townsfolk a guy gave me a bit of an on try to to move. And talk with people.
Perhaps more frequently than other people did but certainly as far as the tribe was concerned.
That wasn't what i wanted to know about me even know a lot of questions i even.
I guess one of the reasons that i was able to survive it all was that i had a reputation for being an anti psychiatrist.
Well that khomeini's bizarre in the extreme. Anti psychiatry. Was that. Interesting. Deviation. That.
Occurred in the light sixty's. With. Ron lange the. The british psychiatrist who discovered existentialism which.
Most psychiatrists in the fifty's and sixty's.
And before that of course knew nothing about but he was ice psychiatrist who read existentialism and.
There were a number of. Who did but he.
Importantly then decided of course that somebody who was paranoid and who was rejecting.
You know the dominant paradigm. Through their paranoia.
Was probably more in contact with reality than the people who didn't. A very romantic and sentimental notion.
With which i was absolutely captivated. As a young psychiatrist. You know when various. People with.
Terrible mental illness. Even when i was a try in a. Expounded on. The theories that.
You know that i was likely to be ona lighted by various forces in the society and. Their predatory and capitalist.
Parents. I mean i was only too willing to hear this and to hear it as a valid.
Interpretation of reality and to therefore see them. Being dealt with as if i was sick.
An invalid died and having those experiences invalidated. As. Definitely part of the problems. That was.
I was quite comfortable with the libel of being an anti psychiatrist even though.
I worked with people who were seriously. Italy ill and. Use drugs and treated them in fairly conventional wise.
That's not to say that i didn't try the other one in the research project i referred to earlier was one where i really
was trying very hard to deal with mad people as if i were totally responsible human beings as if i were.
Creating the sorts of delimiters that i got into as authentic. Poor trials of. Of their political and personal reality.
But of course. It just didn't help them. All if it didn't help them suddenly.
Validating the paranoid and delusional experiences of people who have some sort of mental disorders. Is useful.
I'm sure it provides them with some comfort. But actually on its own and.
It's really not going to stop them from probably perishing. Or killing somebody else.
And you know i am a doctor and other people are doctors or psychiatrists because for some reason we. We decided that.
It's probably a mark of a human community if i die and let those people die or or carry other people or why with them.
Because of this trying to beliefs. But anyhow i think the fact that i was now known as an anti psychiatrist.
And that i'd suffered. Not even considerably from my peers. You know i filed me in my exams the first time.
But i mean i turned up at this. You know. Formidable and. Important final exam in psychiatry with.
You know i head down to my wife's in a duffel.
Probably be in things i mean the next time i sat for the exam which you're allowed to do every six months i wore a
three piece suit and. Had a whisky first and had my hair cut and past the exam. But i mean the fact that i was an n.t.
Psychiatrist and a high profile one in the media in the early seventy's.
Probably also help me to be quite accepted by the tribe. Up there. Well i yes i think that.
It's very hard to know of course whether. Naman or whether the fact that my friend.
Petroff and i set up a psychiatric service in lismore is what's responsible for the fact that there's probably.
On a percentage by service. A few more seriously mentally ill people around him and then they have.
They would be around tamworth. You know when you set up a psychiatric service.
Then you what you attract a group of people who are likely to need and use that service.
While we set up the psych service in seventy three in lismore. And women gets going in seventy three. And i think that.
To some extent. Two things are mixed in there is only slightly more. Genuinely mentally ill people around there.
Than they would be. In any other population. But they certainly are.
And the capacity of that community to tolerate people whose. Mood swings.
Can create a bit of havoc in their own lives in the eyes of a loved ones. It's probably greater out there.
And the capacity of the community to tolerate people who live. Almost a feral. Sort of law and.
Have some very disturbed sort of beliefs. Is certainly greit than it is elsewhere and. There's no doubt that.
You know there is a greater incidence of madness but i don't think for a moment. That.
That's just the environment that's producing the madness. Just drift.
Adrift of a group of pretty deviant people into a situation where i can survive more easily and.
Less obviously than than predict practically anywhere else in this trial yet. Oh well i mean. I only see that group of.
Ferals who probably do have schizophrenia. I have no doubt that there is. You know shadow. I ran a central.
Central group of.
Heroic mad people larry as i shared with people who are less heroic
and less mad with whom i'm never coming to any contact and.
I think that there might have eisen is something which probably is not. Not too different from a bi sick.
And i call rejection of the dominant paradigm just as ours was twenty years ago.
I remember and one of the reasons that i moved out of name. Because when i left. Paradise valley after a few years.
After ten years really. I moved into a house in town. Right in the middle of town. And one of the.
Ferals began shooting on my front lawn. And he wasn't cries he at all he was drunk and. A few other things.
But he certainly wasn't mentally ill or anything like that and one time after each shot on the lawn and i went out
and walked by him on my why out of the car to go to work. I just said look that is really. Von. And i mean.
He gave me this highly articulate. Rival about how it was his lawn. I mean it was my lawn but i mean it was his lawn.
And i couldn't cope with that.
I just thought i'm just i'm not going to be able to live here i mean i can hear what he's signing.
You know this is his planet this is his long form. He has got as he said he's got a right to sheet on this loan.
As a matter of fact at the time. I hadn't realized the rights were all bullshit.
I must say that i have chinese doing twenty years and all. And some of my ideas have.
Have distilled into something quite different from what i would be for so i now if somebody said something to me about
have i had a right to shoot on my lawn. I probably wouldn't react the way i did then but i was.
They plea moved and i couldn't think of an argument against it. And i began.
In my mind thinking of leaving nimba because i would have to because simply because i couldn't cope with him cheating
on my lawn but i thought it was for him to shit on my lawn. So i would have to guy.
Because i i mean i could ask him to go. I just i remember once. On the phone.
A fairly feral black was living there for a while and he ran up and. I had hundred dollar fine bill. On my five and.
I said to him. This is unbelievable. You. You'll have to pony this money and he said he got me money and.
I'm not going to piet and. Why should i pirate you know. You've got the fine.
And you've got the money and i needed to michael a fine cause to perth and.
I remember i burst into tears and i said well all i can do is ask you to leave.
I can only ask you to leave we didn't have a room where you could actually sane somebody why that was a second the
counties in where. You know when somebody asserted to me a right to be high even a why that was seriously.
Impacting on me i couldn't think of an argument against that. And i moved off the valley. I applied the bill.
And moved off the valley because he wouldn't. And i moved out of town. Because this guy wouldn't. Not she's on my lawn.
And what was the question again that. Yes yes yes yes yes yes. Well i mean i've worked in my own mind now.
I'm on to a different. I'm on a. I'm on a very different track. I i believe that there has been a serious.
There is a cataclysm. Approaching that. Who espouse the notion of individual freedom. Personal freedom and the right.
To do things are indeed. Now i think represent the most serious danger to the planet. But whereas i thought.
Before that those sorts of rights. Were important for a person. To feel as if i were moving their world around them.
I now feel of course. That that i absolutely run contrary. To a certain human connectedness. Which.
At least i now know is much more important in me feeling like a worthwhile human being.
Groups that are about empowerment and.
Groups that are about still factual and groups that are about personal freedom now. I think. Terrible.
I think it's all wrong. It's rather it's a similar problem to the problem where democracy.
Which is one hundred fifty years old is a word and a concept. If you don camp and greeks. Where democracy. The word.
And the via guy dear. Has actually been hijacked by a group of people who say it means freedom of choice.
And that without the freedom to choose there is no such thing as democracy. Well of course democracy.
In its original conception had nothing to do with the freedom of choice particularly nothing to do with the idea that
you therefore have to have six things to choose from.
Or you're not operating in a democracy i mean that the whole idea of bringing freedom and choice. In.
I guess to simply boast of materialism and consumerism. Has simply been a terribly and incredibly ingenious.
Hijacking of. One of the aspects of democracy. Into now. What democracy now means is that you have freedom to choose.
Well. The idea that you have to be a self determining human being has been hijacked. Again.
By a group of people who for some reason. Don't like to think that.
In the final analysis we are responsible for other people as well as for half selves just as responsible for other
people as ass elves i mean we are very vulnerable creatures for the first fifteen years of our life and
and by sickly for the how all of our lives we do depend upon the goodwill of all of the other humans on the planet.
To survive. And things like goodwill and loving kindness and all of those sorts of things.
Actually can disappear entirely. If you insist that the most important thing for a human being to have.
Is self-determination and. Free will because you're really arguing that. You shouldn't be cowed worst. Impacted.
Influenced by some other person. But that's an absolute nonsense. You absolutely need.
Advocacy influence connectedness. All of those things in order to be a human being.
So i'm personally against the human rights movement. I have realized in the last few years. That i fail and.
Interestingly i've never joined amnesty and i've. And i've wondered why i never. And amnesty.
And i want to be joining amnesty. Because i don't believe that the human rights movement.
Is the why out of a terrible problem at the moment. I think the human responsibility movement is the y. Axis.
And i don't hear anybody talking about it. And i personally am terribly uncomfortable about.
You know the freedom to previous say. This is just an absolutely. Unnatural start for human brain.
And most of the things that have now entered the discourse is if i are right. I think i have very very serious pot of.
Well i can be uncomfortable about the eilean ice in that we are building into democracies. Now.
We're heading headlong a-y. From the human connectedness and. The tribal. Stuff. Which is just.
Crucial to the human to human being. Yes yes. Being your brother's keeper. In the broadest sense of it. Yes.
I am my brother's keeper. Just as i would want him to be mine and.
You know the personal freedom and autonomy but tommy what the hell is autonomy.
You can't move without impacting another human being whose.
But is critical to your house you can make an action without impacting another human being whose comfort is ultimately
going to be incredibly influential on yours. So you know i find myself now. Feeling like a totally. Voice.
About this whole human rights issue. Because certainly i mean when i when i speak up about it. You know.
People look at me as if i'm some sort of fascist. Maybe i am. But i'm actually coming from something which is i think.
Deeply spiritual. But i'm happy to call that stuff. Connectedness. If. Spiritual mike's people feel i'm comfortable.
I'm on about human connectedness the. Into dependence. Of our mind of our mental stuff and of our mental law.
And this insistence on. Individuality. Personal autonomy. Choice and all of those sorts of things.
I think is just the natural extension of the political disasters of the last hundred years of democracy
and it's reinterpretation. And psychology. And it's horrendous eilean eisen. From united through.
Empiricism and behaviorism it's. It's a leap a y.
From law and compassion which of course are they only things that are really important things.
Oh yes absolutely absolutely the events. The tribal of a and the concerts. The five clubs. The feasts. The dances.
The ritual that was what it was about for me growing old with people who are now. On for twenty years. Yes.
All of those things were the most important things. As well as for me. The actual reconnecting with growing tree and.
And the seasons. Which i think. Deeply important for all human beings.
And even though i lived for the first ten years of my life in the country.
I then spent the next twenty years during my education. In the city. And i had. I had lost a lot of the. The warmth.
And the maining. Of knowing that it was a full moon or or.
Or that the exclusive feeling that comes the countryside after a violent storm i'm in the clear.
I'd lost all of that stuff you do in a city you're just not conscious of whether it's winter or summer or running
or not. The human. Tribal cell a bright tree. Things were wonderfully narcing.
And then reconnecting with the tree and the earth was the second thing that. You know i mixed the house thing from a.
Well it's it is what it's what. Continues to give my life its meaning. Yeah.
Well actually the pic is both something that still goes on blue navajo sadly has been overtaken by some rather violent
episodes of life as. In the last ten years of course has alcohols been. Become.
It's really made a comeback in the in the alternative community certainly the level of violence has increased with the
level of increased alcohol consumption in the first ten years or so
when we were all just a miking diaper largely at any sort of tribal gatherings. Very much more peaceful but blue knob.
Was of course a very special venue on the new year's eve in the full moon dances that we had a blue knob
or weiss just with the musicians.
Getting together getting a repertoire together for the show there were the usual musician's egos
but basically it was often possible to have ten or fifteen people up on the stand.
And of course we were all wanting to be heard but we were all wanting to hear each other too. For the most precious.
And reinforcing. Parts of blue. On a saturday night on a full moon or a new year was just the most extraordinary event.
I can't i can't walk. Brought us all together.
Unless it was for other people as it was for me that is a tribe of like minded people who were not going to.
Fall our career path. Which would continually disrupt their relationships with each other.
That's what it was for may i knew that you know i had to be a successful psychiatrist i would have to mike a number of.
Career moves that would be geographical and i would lose my group over and over again. So i think that.
I would hazard a guess that really.
All of the people that arrived up there with the view that i was going to study there. And not.
Mike the usual geographical moves that go with contemporary life.
All were there for that sign tribal reasons i wanted to mike a connection with a group of people whose vices i would
all know. All the time and grow old without people even if i said i went there.
So that i could get into alternative power or so i could get into anything else.
I really feel that it was the desire to have this not primary group at woodstock.
Still that took a saw a funny story about a name and yes. Yes. Before we moved up on to the fire.
We used to go up there for the holidays.
And of course we'd all had mushrooms i guess touring the festival and that sort of thing but.
I think it was the very next holidays we all found ourselves up there would've been christmas seventy three.
And the how. Of the group of us. The twelve of us who'd bought land america kids. Three or four kids were up there.
And we were just arriving in dribs and drabs as we've driven up from sydney and the mushroom.
Where athan the cash it was everywhere. And so we were going to have everyone was going to drop some mushrooms.
And most of us. Had had some mushrooms during the festival but whether there was one.
I wonder for a woman who had never had any mushrooms.
And so we all talked to my friends and got into the various types that you get into.
When you're tripping on mushrooms and all night just about an ally. That. This wonderful woman. Had grabbed the broom.
And she was dashing around the paddock. Where we were all lying in various sites or. Or whatever.
And she was sweeping the cap path. Into little piles. And at this point i should say she's a virgo.
And she was always the tightest person in the car me and she was in charge of the washing up and the cooking
and all of this sort of thing. And she had preceded the time the casket in the paddock.
And when i said to him what the hell are you doing she said.
When's this bloody stuff going to start with the rest of us sort of collapsed. You know.
I think she realized that it was working. You know. You've asked me what i think about naman and drugs.
The dockside of name the. It's now narcotics. It's very strong. Saying in niemann well obviously you know.
From the amount of time i've been talking to you about marijuana and mushrooms and. And those sorts of things.
For me the. The drug taking part of the name and was important. So i'm not at all surprised.
Of course that there is no. I very obvious. Drug culture name. And not surprised that. Of course it is.
That rather than just being.
Mara weiner and mushrooms and nice sorts of things which of course are harmful i'm not suggesting they're not.
But rather than it being those things it's now my colleagues. To be truthful i believe there is just one.
Very simple explanation. But it's not an opinion that would be easy to to prove.
But i think it is almost entirely relights. To their why the police actually three ill about people like me.
And about all of us who've come up there. I think that the police. Well let's start a step back. I think in v.
Is one of the most. Common human failings i mean it's not. It's not a.